sorry this is smoking scoop this right
on top
this is definitely wrong this is
definitely wrong
[Music]
welcome back to chef out of water i'm
alexis a chef who's always up for a
challenge
i've taken to the internet you to see
what appliance i should make a
three-course meal with
okay let's see what we have this time
[Music]
waffle iron okay you know i've never
made anything that isn't a waffle in a
waffle iron
but i think there's possibilities here i
think i'm gonna have to get creative i
feel pretty good about this i'd say my
confidence level right now is a
nine out of ten question do i get more
than one waffle iron
yes we get two two waffle irons
guys this is gonna be great okay a
waffle iron i know that like you can use
a waffle iron to make so many things
like a frittata
hash browns you know you can use it to
kind of
you know make things into a waffle shape
i'm curious though if there's anything
you can use this for
that doesn't look like a waffle
[Music]
looks like someone tried to make
mozzarella sticks that feels
really ambitious acorn squash
lots of eggy things i think i may be
still scarred from the microwave
episode
if i have two of these no problem
confidence level a nine i feel good
about this famous last words every time
but i really feel excited this is hot
after doing some research i've come up
with a plan i'm gonna start with dessert
working backwards as i usually do and
i'm gonna make a chocolate cake
waffle i'm also gonna make some
chocolate whipped cream
some roasted cherries and kind of layer
it all together
so hopefully you know looking at it you
wouldn't think well fine
okay so to get started i'm going to add
all my dry ingredients together
i have not been working out in
quarantine or ever
you know doing the old spoon trick to
get an accurate measurement some
cocoa powder pinch of salt salt brings
out the sweetness
and some baking powder it's going to
give it that kind of like puffy
cakey quality and i'm just going to
whisk this all together
so far things are going very well i mean
confidence levels so far i mean this is
a 10
right got my dry ingredients i'm gonna
move on to the wet ingredients
so sugar is actually a wet ingredient
fun fact
and some milk quite a lot of milk i
haven't made waffles in
two years see how this goes some
vegetable oil keep it moist
a little bit of vanilla extract just you
know more flavor
does anyone actually measure vanilla
extract don't think i ever have
two eggs wow
big shell rookie move this is like a
comically inappropriate size
okay there we go
now wet ingredients go into the dry
ingredients
now usually i have my helper ryan but at
times have changed so it's
just me today this looks very wet oh
gosh
will this go in a waffle iron it feels
like too wet to do that
i think i'm gonna add a little more
flour or maybe that is the texture of
waffles
or cake i don't know i make it a cake to
go in a waffle
maker just want to get this batter
really smooth
really just been sitting on the couch so
this feels like a real workout
okay it looks totally fine i'm gonna put
this to the side
i'm gonna start whipping some cream
getting these heated up
so at least like a few things can happen
at once one of them can go maximum heat
and one can go medium heat
we've been here before but this requires
some whipped cream
and as always i don't have a hand mixer
it's gonna take a while
actually using this small bowl and a big
whisk is going
much faster it's beautiful okay i'm
gonna add some sugar
i'm not tasting as i go
and i know i've made this mistake before
but i know this is sugar
i can see it add a little sugar i mean
this whipped cream looks really pretty
oh no oh no
it's salt just a little bit
i wanted to add some chocolate to my
whipped cream i had an idea that if i
put some bars of chocolate
in aluminum foil and put it in the
waffle iron
that it'll melt okay this is super hot
so
i assume you can put foil in a waffle
iron just gonna go with it over here
also very hot i'm gonna give this a
spray and
i've got a half cup here i think that
looks good just smooth it out
[Applause]
if this is a bust i have a lot more
batter so we're okay this is not like a
traditional black forest
trifle cake whatever you want to call it
but inspired by you know
oh there's some chocolate coming out the
top okay
yes it totally works wow
wow wow okay gotta work quickly it's not
a ton of chocolate but
let's see how this goes this is the best
idea i've ever had
amazing wow oh sorry this is smoking
smoking typical
i'm gonna put waffle master on my resume
this is
amazing up next so typically for a black
forest cake you would soak the cherries
in like a dark cherry syrup with some
cherry liqueur
i'm not gonna do that i just thought i
could put some of the cherries like in
the waffle iron to kind of like roast
them or get them softened and
maybe get a little more depth of flavor
i'm just gonna put a few down
actually i'm gonna put them all down i
don't know
it's on really high heat so i think
these are gonna go pretty quickly
meanwhile i kind of think this is done
oh okay the waffle just ripped a little
bit when i was trying to pick it up and
it is
not cooked yet so i think i just need to
be patient for a few minutes
but i'm gonna put the waffle in here i'm
gonna tear it up and then i think i can
start layering
my trifle oh
um the cherries are letting a ton of
juice out but they look great you know
they're kind of like saucy
a little broken down the waffle still
looks good
hmm it
feels cooked through it still has some
good springiness
it smells incredible i'll do a layer in
the bottom
no till i'm disguising the waffle i
realized i'm putting like a hot waffle
in just maybe not the best idea and a
layer of this like chocolate whipped
cream
and some cherries oh those are some
syrupy cherries
this looks so good it is totally
unrecognizable maybe not a good way but
that's okay oh
having a moment to myself wow honestly a
shame that no one else can have this
this is
so good and then some more cherries okay
it looks kind of crazy
oh it's dripping outside oh god what
have i done should i
dump the syrup on it
the answer was no okay i think the
hardest part about this
that it kind of looks like a disaster oh
my god
it's kind of like a sticky mess right
now but it also looks pretty good i'm
gonna move on to the next course
my trifle is in the fridge so i'm gonna
move on to my appetizer course
i'm gonna make an okonomiyaki which is
like a japanese savory pancake
it's got cabbage and egg you can also
add other vegetables but i'm gonna keep
it pretty simple i've never made
okonomiyaki before
but i really really really love it it's
going to be in the shape of a waffle but
it gets
covered with sauce and bonita flakes and
more scallions so
i think it'll look kind of like this
pile of stuff rather than a waffle
okay to get started going back to my
flour good pinch of salt
and my eggs and i'm just going to add it
right to the flour and stir it all
together this kind of looks like the
beginning of
crepes so i'm just going to use green
cabbage and scallions for my
okonomiyaki filling and i just want to
cut it really
thinly so that it's kind of like more of
an even pancake and you're not like
i'm gonna try mixing in this cabbage
before i have the scallions just because
this is gonna take a lot more work and
if this doesn't work out
you know it's easier to start over this
feels this is
this is definitely wrong
wrong maybe i'll put this in and see if
this works and save the scallions
okay i'm gonna clean up i'm gonna clean
up
and then uh sort the situation out
waffle iron's heating up i don't know
why i chose to make something that i've
never made before so therefore i cannot
verify
if it's correct or not just gonna
i'm just gonna scoop this right on top
like i guess
flatten it out a little this is like
okonomiyaki is so good and i feel like
so far i'm not really selling it
it gets okonomiyaki sauce on top so i've
got some oyster sauce
ketchup and worcestershire shire
worcestershire sauce worcestershire
oh god stir it all together i mean
it has the right look
let's hope this works check in time
okay i think i know that this is wrong
this is not
happening so i'm gonna start over okay
so i think my
previous okonomiyaki was too thick i
think there's too much flour not enough
eggs so i'm upping the eggs
taking down the flour a lot of salt
going from one cup to a half cup
this already feels better just lighter
you know
okay cabbage and i feel confident so i
think i will add some scallions
that feels good for now spray this down
so it's ready to go
again using my hands oh this feels so
much better
so i think it's supposed to be like just
more like lightly held together
with the egg rather than whatever i did
last time
[Music]
don't do that at home
[Music]
okay cool i'm gonna clean up and
hopefully by the time i get back
this will be ready okay this one smells
right
looking way more right okay i'm gonna
cut the rest of the scallions
hopefully this will be done soon
confidence took a little hit there
i'm like simmering at a seven right now
okay there's some raw eggs still
on the side but it's almost there so
i've got some nori that i'm just gonna
use some scissors to slice up
i've got my okonomiyaki sauce cupid
mayonnaise and bonito flakes so all of
that's going to go right on top just
like
cut it into thin little strips it still
feels
thick but i wonder if that's just kind
of like inevitable with the waffle iron
shape
it's getting pressed up you know to
create that like classic shape so i'm
gonna go with it it's fine
if it's terrible i'm the one eating it
okay does it look better on this side
yes oh my god okay gorgeous okay i'm
gonna go so you kind of go like back and
forth
oh god i'm so sorry to everyone who
actually knows how to make this
and the kiwi mayonnaise and then bonita
flakes
dried cured fish and you just kind of
put these on
in a pile on top they're pretty pungent
so
if you're not into fish you might not
like them some of these like little
sliced nori and then i'm just gonna add
some scallions
i feel pretty proud of myself because
this does not look like a waffle
okonomiyaki done i'm going to move on to
my last course
so for my last course i'm going to make
black garlic butter
rubbed cod with some grilled scallions i
mean i really think no one's gonna know
that this was made in a waffle iron you
know
well you all know but uh it could fool
someone so black garlic is
just fermented garlic and the cloves
they're really easy to peel
unlike you know regular garlic they just
get kind of like soft
they just kind of melt away so i'm just
going to get a few cloves
and mash them into a paste and add them
to butter easy enough like how soft they
are they just kind of
press right under the pressure you can
put this on roast chicken
vegetables i mean honestly pretty much
anything you could add it to a
vinaigrette
it looks like incredible flavor there oh
the butter
is not room temperature okay i think
this is nothing that a waffle iron can't
melt so it's probably going to get
pretty hot but i'm just going to let it
go for a second grab some scallions i'm
just going to
trim the tops of the scallions i'm going
to leave them whole
so they can kind of be like draped
around the fish and just going to douse
them in some olive oil
and i think for these i'm gonna do it on
high i like to broil whole scallions so
they get like
really just like crispy and i mean
almost burnt
so i kind of think the same thing could
happen in the waffle iron
these are a little big for the waffle
iron but i think i can just move them
down when they start to get charred
that looks ridiculous okay back to the
butter
oh you can hear them start to sizzle
i feel very grateful for two waffle
irons right now oh yeah
i realize this doesn't look very
appetizing but the flavor is going to be
so
good can i add a little pepper salt
amazing color starting that's a good
start
i feel pretty good right now i mean
we'll see how the fish cooks
but everything is working out i feel
like the the result of that okonomiyaki
really like boosted my confidence
there's still some butter chunks here
but actually i'm just gonna let it sit
moving on to the fish so i've got some
beautiful black cod here
this is way too big for waffle iron so
i'm just gonna cut this
and i'm gonna rub the black garlic
butter directly on it
again i know this doesn't look super
appealing but the flavor
is what we're after i thought black cod
would be a good fish to use
because it's thinner it's pretty
delicate you don't want it to cook
through
so it's not gonna have to be in there
for too long i mean i've never put black
cod in a waffle iron so i really don't
know but that's what i assume
i'm just gonna add some olive oil and
just wrap it up
this is this is weird okay here we go
these scallions are really sizzling now
oh wow i'm gonna just now load them down
if i was making this on the stove um
maybe five to seven minutes not too long
um you know you want it to just like
flake away with your fork black cut is
so delicate and such
like a sweet fish that you really don't
want to overcook it
oh i forgot i wanted to do a charred
lemon too okay
back with the lemon i thought it'd be
nice to char the lemons just to get you
know a little more flavor
okay i think these are good to take off
and i'm gonna add some salt actually i
mean this is
can i serve this as the meal plate of
scallions
and the lemons just gonna put them right
down i feel like that'll work again the
fish is going
i'm just gonna turn it around so that it
cooks evenly
i don't really have a backup plan if
this fish doesn't work
so it actually might end up being just
scallions but
we'll see confidence level 10.
i haven't said that in a long time it
smells amazing
oh it's because it's leaking out can i
just take a peek
it's perfect it's like flaking without
doing anything
i mean i don't own a waffle iron but if
i did i might be using it to make fish
this is
insane okay this fish wow this is so
delicate oh my god it might even break
apart
oh my god i mean it might even be
overcooked i'm shocked to say that
so i'm just gonna kind of like arrange
the scallions around
and you know for everyone wondering why
i didn't trim these
they're totally edible whenever i make
scallions i leave the roots on
wow okay let's check these lemons
i kind of think because of the shape of
the waffle iron this is like as good as
they're gonna get but there is some
color
okay black garlic butter cod with
scallions made in a waffle iron
i'm feeling pretty jazzed i've got to be
honest like
level 10 confidence all the way through
i'm so excited about this i feel really
proud of myself i feel like i've come a
long way i think i'm gonna dig right
into the okonomiyaki
looks cooked
[Music]
it's white good it doesn't taste exactly
like okunomiyaki it's a little thicker
i think i could have put a little less
batter in there but the flavor is like
amazing i think you know one out of ten
i'd give this an eight
okay moving on to the black cod the fish
is already flaking apart
[Music]
it's shocking
[Music]
this is really really good putting
myself in someone else's shoes i would
never guess this was made in a waffle
iron this is so
cool i feel so proud of myself i love it
you know i think the fish is overcooked
by
maybe a minute but it's still really
delicate melts in your mouth 8.5 i'm so
sad that i can't share this food with
anyone
i have to tell you i've been waiting for
this all day this is a crazy big bite
but i've got some of the waffle
some of the chocolate whipped cream the
cherries
here's resolution the waffle consistency
all teared up like
becomes a perfect vessel for the cream
to get soft but actually still has
enough structure
the cherries are just you know they got
kind of roasted
they're kind of like falling apart in
your mouth they're delicious
this might be one of my most successful
meals yet really i'm like
sorry one more bite
[Music]
overall i couldn't be happier this is
incredible this was so fun
waffle iron i had a good feeling about
this but honestly
i surpassed my own expectations i think
this is one of my best meals today
let me know in the comments which one of
these dishes you'd like to try
i'll see you next time
[Music]
you